all right our very first question is
from joe fryer today show and nbc news
go for it joe
hey there gene congratulations this has
been like absolutely one of my favorite
shows in a long time so congratulations
thank you
i mean
to have made a show that just brought so
much joy to people and made so many
people laugh and then to win for it what
does that mean to you
oh my gosh everything i mean
especially now when
it's nice to make people smile and laugh
but uh you know when you do something
that is that is uh
meant to entertain like that that's the
whole thing is the audience reaction
it's sort of like being on stage you
know
it's um
that's what you live for is you know how
you're affecting people
and so it's been just more than we ever
could have expected
very good congrats thank you thank you
joe and next up we've got heather
brooker from knbc go for it heather hi
gene congratulations thank you
you have had such an incredible career
i've been a fan of yours since designing
women a million years ago
i would love to know
um there was such a look of reverence
and respect from everyone in the room
when your name was announced what does
it mean for you to be recognized by your
colleagues in this way it's huge it was
very moving and
i didn't expect that and
you know to have your peers respect you
is
huge and um
and it's it's meant a lot because it's
been such a difficult
um
last six months so this has been
something that has been um
kind of a strange counterpoint but it's
been very much appreciated
thank you so much and congratulations
thank you
thank you heather next up we have lauren
zema from entertainment tonight
hi lauren
hi gene i'm so sorry you have me in
tears a little bit um we're all so happy
for you and
no it's okay i i um we were all so moved
by your speech
and um i'm so sorry for your loss but i
was just wondering you know what what
you'll kind of be thinking of as you go
home tonight and knowing that you're
able to have this moment after
everything you've been through and and
what your husband would say to you if
if you were here now
um
oh gosh well he'd be very happy for me i
i was i was thrilled to share it with my
youngest
and uh he's ecstatic
and um
so that that was really that was really
special um
you know i unfortunately have to go to
work at the crack of dawn tomorrow so i
have to can't party too much tonight so
um
but yeah no this is
to be rewarded for something that you're
particularly proud of
is really nice if you did something that
you thought was kind of okay
you didn't feel like it was your best
and then you got rewarded for it that
wouldn't feel that great
but to
like i said to be really proud of
something and then to be
honored for it that's extra extra
special
well thanks gene you're incredible and
thank you for sharing that i i thank you
you touched a lot of people tonight and
you're incredible thank you thank you
thank you lauren and our final question
for gene is going to come from david
with extra go for it david
hi david hi gene uh congratulations so
well deserved uh i'm i'm such a fan of
your work and watched you in both mayor
and this show and i was just
blown away at um you know your
versatility your ability to
jump from from that
role in such a dark you know serious to
this one i wonder um
i wonder
you know i guess my question is
because lauren stole my question i
wanted to ask you about your husband and
she took that one so tell us if you will
what what might we expect from season
two of hacks
gosh uh well i'm not gonna be in the
writers room so
i i do
i do know that as promised at the end of
season one
i will be going on the road a bit
to try out new material although i think
they want to definitely
uh keep her you know based in in l.a
um that she will be she will be uh going
out a bit to little comedy clubs and
trying out material and i do know that
they will be exploring her relationship
with her sister
which is
um
it's been a huge a traumatic part of her
life that's all i know so far